Why are there are
seven million people,
and why do each one of us
have our own fingerprint?
Even twins have
different fingerprints--
Why?
Who are otherwise
genetically identical.
Why?
Would you rather
we were all the same?
No.
I'm--
Why is that more odd
to you than the fact
that we all have
different personalities?
We have different talent.
But personalities
can be based on--
On what you learn.
Environment-- nurture,
and not just nature.
Right.
So I thought about
it the other day,
and it kind of made me spin.
It's just like, we all have
different fingerprints.
OK, I get it.
Grand design?
Well, so it's an
intriguing fact.
But here's something
that may relate.
Most people who could be
born will never be born,
will never even exist.
Like sperm.
OK.
Yeah, sure.
Yeah.
One gets in--
- I mean, it's science.
The rest don't.
So where do they go?
They're part of the
number of human beings
that will never, ever be born.
Well, is that because
there's not enough souls?
There's already so many
people in the world, though.
That would be something
if you ran out of souls.
What would a soulless
person look like?
Do you believe
you have a soul?
I don't know what a soul is.
I know there's what--
here's something that
freaks me out every day.
Every morning, I wake
up and I say, how is it
that every morning I wake up
as me and not as someone else?
Oh, yeah.
Yeah.
I have that same
feeling sometimes.
It's like, this
is weird being me.
What is it like being you?
- Right.
Well, that's what I'm saying.
It's like, why am
I me every day?
How does that happen?
[explosion sound]
We have these
electrochemicals in our head.
And somehow, that's me.
And I'm me every day,
as far as I know.
As far as--
I wonder, if I woke up as a
different person each day,
would I know it?